the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones and
house of the dragon update video
well my friends i have some very
unfortunate news
according to an article released by
deadline hbo has stopped filming for
house of the dragon because someone
working on the set now has kova 19.
i was afraid this would happen
now it's actually not as bad as it
sounds deadline's article also says
filming should begin again in only a few
days they said
hbo has shut down production on the game
of thrones successor show house of the
dragon due to covet 19.
we're hearing that the uk shoot has been
stopped for two days after a positive
case in zone a
which includes the cast and crew now
that is actually really good news
because they were making a lot of us
quarantine for several weeks over here
in america
as long as nothing else happens this
won't really be that different than
having the weekend off
now it also goes on to say deadline
understands that a production member
tested positive
and in compliance with industry
guidelines will isolate
and close contacts are required to
quarantine
filming will resume on wednesday so as
you can see it's actually not as bad as
it initially sounded
i will now step away from the ledge i'll
be honest when i woke up earlier and got
a glimpse of the headline i nearly
fainted right back to sleep assuming the
news would be much worse but that was
until i actually was able to read the
full thing
hopefully whoever it was that got sick
will make a full recovery
if it were up to me i would have
rhaenyra and daemon bring fire and blood
to house coved
as always if they release any more
information i will inform you as soon as
i can
for now i will keep the update video
short and sweet
make sure you subscribe if you want to
stay up to date on any and all
information regarding a song of ice and
fire
game of thrones house of the dragon or
any of the other shows
hbo has in development either way i will
be making another video very soon
i hope all of you have a great day
thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
[Music]
so
you